The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So we have been looking at the
problem of phase transitions
from the perspective of
a simple system which
is a piece of magnet.
And we find that if we change
the temperature of the system,
there is a critical
temperature, Tc,
that separates
paramagnetic behavior
on the high temperature side
and ferromagnetic behavior
on the low temperature side.
Clearly in the
vicinity of this point,
whether you're on one
side or the other,
the magnetization
is small and we
are relying on that to
make us a good parameter
to expand things in.
The other thing is
that we anticipated
that over here there
are long wavelength
fluctuations of the
magnetization field
and so we did averaging and
defined a statistical field,
this magnetization as
a function of position.
Then we said, OK, if I'm
just changing temperature,
what potential is the
behavior of the probability
that I will see in my sample
some particular configuration
of this magnetization field?
So there is a functional
that governs that.
And the statement
that we made was
that whatever this
functional is,
I can write it as the
exponential of something
if I want.
This probability is positive.
I will assume that it is--
locally there is a probability
density that I will
integrate across the system.
Probability density
is a function
of whatever magnetization
I have around point x.
And so then when we expanded
this, what did we have?
We said that the terms that
are consistent with rotational
symmetry have to be things like
m squared, m to the fourth,
and so forth.
In principal, there
is a long series
but hopefully
since m is small, I
don't have to include that
many terms in the series.
And additionally, I can have
an expansion in gradient
and the lowest order
term in that series
was the gradient of m squared
and potentially higher
order terms.
OK?
We said that we
could, if we relied
on looking at the most probable
configuration of this weight,
make a connection
between what is going
on here and the
experimental observation.
And essentially the only
thing that we needed to do
was to basically
start T from here,
so T was made to be
proportional to T minus Tc.
And then we could explain
these kinds of phenomena
by looking at the
behavior of the most
probable magnetization.
Now I kind of said
that we are going
to have long wavelength
fluctuations.
There was one case
where we actually
saw a video of those long
wavelength fluctuations
and that was for the case
of critical opalescence
taking place at the liquid gas
mixture at its critical point.
Can we try to quantify
that a little bit better?
The answer is yes, we can do so
through scattering experiments.
And looking at the
sample was an example
of a scattering
experiment, which
if you want to do
more quantitatively,
we can do the following-
we can say that there
is some incoming field,
electromagnetic wave that
is impingent on the system.
It's a pass on
incoming wave vector k.
It sort of goes
through the sample
and then when it comes out,
it gets scattered and so what
I will see is some
k [INAUDIBLE] that
comes from the other
part of the system.
In principle, I guess I can
put a probe here and measure
what is coming out.
And essentially it will
depend on the angle
towards which this has rotated.
If I asked well, how
much has been scattered?
We'd say, well it's
a complicated problem
in quantum mechanics.
Let's say this is a quantum
mechanical procedure-
you would say that there's
an amplitude that you have
the scattering that is
proportional to some overlap
between the kind of state
that you started with,
what we started is an
incoming wave with k initial,
presumably there is the
initial state of my sample
before the wave hits
it, and then I end up
with the final configuration
which is k f, whatever
the final version
of my system is.
Now between these two,
I have to put whatever
is responsible for
scattering this wave so there
is in some sense some
overall potential
that I have to put over here.
Now let's think about the
case of this thing being,
say, a mixture of
gas and liquid,
well what is scattering light?
Well, it is the individual
atoms that are scattering light
and there are lots of them.
So basically I have to sum over
all of the scattering elements
that I have my system.
Let's say I have a u for a
scattering element, i that
is located at position--
maybe bad choice,
let's call it sum over alpha.
X alpha is the
position of let's say
the atom that is scattered here.
OK?
So now since I'm dealing
with, say, linear order,
not multiple scattering,
what I can do
is I can basically
take this sum outside.
So this thing is
related to a sum
over alpha of the
scattering I would have
for individual elements
that are scattering.
And then roughly each
individual element
will scatter an amount
that I will call sigma q.
If you have elastic
scattering what happens
is that essentially your
initial k simply gets rotated
without changing its magnitude.
So what happens is that
essentially everything
will end up being a function
of this momentum transfer which
is proportional
to q k f minus k i
whose magnitude would be
twice the magnitude of your k
sine of the half of
the angle if you just
do the simple
geometry over there.
So this is for
elastic scattering
which is what we will
be thinking about.
Now the amount that each
individual element scatters
like each atom is
indeed a function
of your momentum transferred
from the scattering probe.
But the thing that
you're scattering from
is something that is
very small like an atom,
so it turns out that the
resulting q will give
significant-- well, the
resulting sigma will vary all
the over scales
where q is related
to the inverse of
whatever is scattering
which is something
that is very large.
So most of this stuff that
is happening at small q, most
of the variation
that is observed,
comes from summing
over the contributions
of the different elements.
So going to the continuum
limit, this becomes an integral
across your system of whatever
the density of the thing that
is scattering is.
Indeed if I'm thinking about
the light scattering experiment
that we saw with critical
opalescence, what you would
be looking at is this
density of liquid
versus gas, which if I
want to convert to q,
I have to do a Fourier
transform here.
And so this is the amplitude of
scattering that I expect and we
can see that it is
directly probing
the fluctuations of
the system, Fourier
transform [INAUDIBLE] number q.
Eventually of course
this is the amplitude
what you will be seeing is
the amount that is scattered,
s of q will be proportional
to this amplitude squared.
We'll have a part that at
small q is roughly constant,
so basically at small q I can
regard this as a constant.
So at small q all
of the variations
is going to come from
this Roth q squared.
Of course again thinking about
the case of the liquid gas
system, where we were seeing the
picture, there were variations,
so there's essentially
lots and lots
of these Roth q's depending
on which instant of time
you're looking at.
And then it would be useful to
do some kind of a time average
and hope that the
time average comes
from the result of a probability
measure such as this.
OK?
So that's the procedure
that we'll follow.
We're going to go slightly
beyond what we did before.
What we did before was we
started with the probability
distribution, such
as this that we
posed on the basis of symmetry
and then calculated singular
behavior of various
thermodynamic functions
such as heat capacity,
susceptibility, magnetization,
et cetera, all of them at
macroscopic quantities.
But this is a
probability that also
works at the level
of microscopics.
It's really a probability as a
function of our configurations
and the way that
that is probed is
through scattering experiments.
So scattering experiments
really probe the Fourier
transform of this probability
that we have posed over here.
OK?
Now again the full probability
that I have written down there
is rather difficult.
Let's say this in the case
of the liquid gas system,
this row would be explicitly
the magnetization.
It would be the fluctuations
of the magnetization
around the mean.
I should note that in
the case of the magnet,
you can say, well how
do you probe things?
In that case you need
something, some probe
that scatters from
magnetization at each point.
And the appropriate probe for
magnetization is neutrons.
So you basically hit the
system with a beam of neutrons
that may be polarizing them
in this particular direction,
their spins-- and they
hit the spins of whatever
is in your sample and
they get scattered
according to this mechanism.
And what you will
be seeing at small q
is related to fluctuations
of this magnetization field.
Think he was looking for that.
Now I realize-- I'm not
going to run after him.
OK.
So teaches them to
leave the room earlier.
OK.
So let's see what
we have to-- we can
do for the case of
calculating this quantity.
Now I'm not going to calculate
it for the nonlinear form,
it's rather difficult.
What I'm going to do is to
sort of expand on the trick
that we were using
last time which
led to this other
point which is to look
at the most probable state.
So basically we looked
at that function
where we were calculating
the subtle point
integration and the
first thing that we
did was to find
the configuration
of the magnetization field
that was the most likely.
And the answer was that
because k is positive,
your magnetization that
extremizes that probability
is something that is uniform,
does not depend on x,
and is pointing all
in one direction.
Let's call it e hat 1.
That is indicating
this one thing
is symmetry breaking in
the zero field limit.
Of course that spontaneous
symmetry breaking
only occurs when t is negative
and for t positive m bar is 0.
For t negative just
minimizing the expression
t m squared plus
u m to the fourth
gives you minus t over 4u.
OK?
So that's the most
probable configuration.
What this thing is
probing is fluctuations so
let's expand around the
most probable configuration.
So let's say that we-- say that
I have thermally excited and m
of x which is m bar plus
a little bit that varies
from each location
to another location,
like if I'm looking at
this critical opalescence,
it's the variation
in density from one
location to another location.
But that is true as
long as I'm looking
at the case of something
that has only one component.
If I have multiple
components, I can also
have fluctuations in the
remaining m minus 1 directions,
and this is n of let's say alpha
go from 2 of phi t of e alpha.
So I have broken the
fluctuations into two types.
I've said that let's say
if you were n equals to 2
your m bar would be pointing
in some particular direction.
And so phi l's correspond
to increasing the length
or decreasing the length
whereas phi t corresponds
to going in the
orthogonal direction which
in general would be n minus
1, different components.
OK?
So I want to ask,
what's the probability
of this set of fluctuations?
All I need to do and
again this is x-dependent
is to substitute into my general
expression for the probability
so for that I need a few things.
One of the things that I need
is the gradient of m squared.
The uniform part has no
gradient so I will either
get the gradient from phi l
squared or I will get gradient
of the n minus 1 component
vector field phi t
that I will simply write as
gradient of phi t squared.
So phi t is an n
minus 1 component.
I can ask, what is m squared?
Basically the first term
I need to put over there,
but m squared, I have to
square this expression.
I will get m bar squared to m
bar phi l plus phi l squared
that comes from the
component that is along e 1.
All the other components
here will add up
to give me the magnitude of
this transverse field that
exists in the other
m minus 1 directions.
The other term that I
need is m to the fourth
and in particular we saw that
it is absolutely necessary
if t is negative to include
the m to the fourth term
because otherwise the
probability that we were
writing just didn't
make sense and we need
to write expressions for
probability that are physically
sensible.
So I just take the line
above and square it.
But I want to only keep
terms to quadratic order.
So to zero order I have m bar
to the fourth to third order
I have-- to first order I
have 4 m bar cubed phi l
then there are a bunch of terms
that are order of phi squared.
Squaring this will give
me 4 m bar squared phi l
squared, but the dot
product of these two terms
will also gives me two
m bar squared phi l
squared for a total of six
m bar squared phi l squared.
And then the phi t
squared comes simply
from twice m bar
squared phi t squared.
And then there's higher order
terms cubic and fourth order m
phi t and phi l
that I don't write
assuming that the fluctuations
that I'm looking at our small
around the most probable state.
OK?
So if I stick with
this quadratics
then the probability
of fluctuations
across my system characterized
by phi l of x and phi t
of x is proportional
to exponential
of minus integral dd x.
I have an overall factor-- well
I have a factor of K over 2
for the first term.
I have a gradient
of phi l squared
and then you can see that
I have a bunch of them.
Let's put the K over 2,
let's put the one-half here.
I have K phi l gradient
of phi l squared.
I'm going to put everything
that has phi l squared in it.
I have here t over 2 phi l
squared from t over 2m squared.
So I have phi l squared.
I have t over 2.
Actually I have taken--
I'm going to make mistakes
unless I put the
one-half over here, too.
I have another phi l
squared from over here.
That gets multiplied
by u so I will get here
plus 12 u m bar squared,
12 rather than 6
because I divided by 2.
And then I have a term that is
K over 2 gradient of the vector
phi t squared.
And then I have t
over 2 phi t squared
and then 2 m bar
squared multiplied by u
becomes 4u m bar squared.
And there are higher order terms
that I will not write down.
Yes?
Did I--
AUDIENCE: You said
phi l [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yes, so the question
is I immediately
jumped to second order, so what
happened to the linear term?
There's a linear term here and
there's a linear term here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let's
write them down.
So the coefficient
of phi l would
be t over 2 m bar plus 4 u
m bar cubed and minimizing
that expression is setting
this first derivative to zero
so if you are expanding around
an extreme on the most probable
state then by
construction you're
not going to get any terms
that are linear either m phi l
or m phi t.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there-- what's
the reason for not including
a term in our
general probability,
a term like [INAUDIBLE]
of m squared?
PROFESSOR: We could.
He said that
essentially that amount
over here to an expansion in
powers of the gradient, which
if I go to Fourier space
this would become q
squared plus n squared would
be q to the fourth, et cetera.
If you are looking at more q
or large wavelengths and so
we are going to focus
on the first few terms.
But they exist just
as they existed
for the phonon spectrum.
We looked at the linear
portion and then realized
that going away
from q equals to 0
generates all kinds
of other steps.
OK?
I mean, these are very important
things to ask again and again
to ultimately convince
yourself, because in reality
that expansion
that I have written
has an infinity of terms in it.
You have to always
convince yourself
that close enough to
the critical point all
of those other terms
that I don't write down
are not going to
make any difference.
OK?
All right.
So that's the weight.
What I'm going to do is
the same thing that we did
last time for the case
of Goldstone modes,
et cetera, which is to go
to a Fourier presentation
so any one of the components, be
the longitudinal or transverse,
I will write as a sum over q e
to the i q dot, x some Fourier
component and then
get a square root of v
just so that the normalization
would look simple.
And if I substitute for phi
of x in terms of phi of q,
just as we saw last
time the probability
will decompose into independent
contribution for each q
because once you
substitute it here,
every quadratic term will have
both a sum over x and-- sorry,
and integral over x
and sums over q and q
prime, e to the i q plus q prime
x the integration over x forces
q and q prime to be
the same up to a sign.
So then we find that the
probability distribution
as a function of these
Fourier amplitudes
phi alpha and phi t
decomposes into a product.
Basically each q mode
is acting independently
of all the others.
And also at the
quadratic level we
see that there is no
crosstalk between transverse
and longitudinal so we will have
one weight for the transverse,
one weight for the longitudinal.
And what's it actually
going to look like?
Essentially it's going
to look like something
that is proportional,
let's say, for phi l,
it is proportional to
phi l of q squared.
I have here something and
then I have k q squared over 2
so then a Fourier transform that
I will get k q squared over 2.
So let's write it in this
fashion, q over 2 q squared
and then that's something
that's not q dependent.
And by convention I will
write it as x e l minus 2.
It has dimensions of
inverse length scale
because q has dimensions
of inverse length scale
so I will shortly define
a length so that these two
terms would have the
same dimensional,
so c l is defined
in that fashion.
And similarly I
have an exponential
that governs k over 2 q
squared plus c t to the minus 2
phi tilde of t of q squared
and this is a vector
so there are n minus
1 components there.
OK?
And you can see that basically
potentially these two terms,
c l and c t are different.
In fact, let's just
write down what they are.
So this coefficient
K over c l squared
is defined to be t plus
12 u m bar squared.
OK?
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now this depends
on whether you are
for t positive or t
negative-- better be positive
since I have written it as one
over some positive quantity--
for t positive, m bar
is 0 so this is just t.
For t negative, then m bar
squared is minus t over 4 u
so this becomes minus 3t,
so this becomes minus 2t.
OK?
And k over c t squared is
t plus 4u m bar squared.
It is t for t positive.
For t negative,
substitute it for m bar
squared, it will give me 0.
OK?
Actually the top one
hopefully you recognize
or you remember from last time.
We had exactly this
expression t and minus
2t when we calculated
the susceptibility.
This was the inverse
susceptibility.
In fact, I can be
now more precise
and call that the inverse of
the longitudinal susceptibility.
And what we have
here is the inverse
of the transverse
susceptibility.
What does that mean?
Let me remind you what
susceptibility is.
Susceptibility is
you have a system
and you put on a
little bit of the field
and then see how the
magnetization responds.
If you are in the ordered
phase so that your system is
spontaneously pointing
in one direction,
then if you put the
field in this direction,
you have to climb this
Mexican hat potential
and you have to pay
a cost to do so.
Whereas if I put it the field
perpendicular, all that happens
is that the
magnetization rotates,
so it can respond without any
cost and that's what this is.
These are really
the Goldstone modes
that we were discussing are the
transverse fluctuations that I
have written before.
So again, we discussed
last time you
break a continual symmetry
you will have Goldstone modes
and these Goldstone
modes are the ones that
are perpendicular to the average
magnetization, if you like.
OK?
So now we have a prediction.
We say that if I look at
these phi phi fluctuations,
I can pick a particular
q, let's say,
and here I have to
put q star in order
to get something
that is non-zero.
Actually that's put here q prime
and then pick two different
and this is alpha and beta.
Well, if I look at this
average since the weight is
the product of contributions
from different q's the answer
will be 0 unless q and
q prime add up to 0.
And if I'm looking
at the same q,
I better make sure that I'm
looking at the same component
because the longitudinal and
transverse component or any
of the n minus 1 transverse
components among each other
have completely
independent Gaussian rates.
If I'm now looking at the same
Gaussian, for the same Gaussian
I can just immediately
read off it's variance
which is K q squared plus
whatever the appropriate c is
for that direction
whether it's c l
or c t potentially
would make a difference.
OK?
Right.
So now we have a prediction
for our experimentals.
I said that these guys
can go and measure
the scattering as a function
of angle at small angle
and they can fit how
much is scattered
as you go as a function of angle
and fit it as a function of q.
So we predict that if
they look at something
that's say like phi l
squared, if you're thinking
about the liquid gas
system that's really
the only thing that
you have because there
is no transverse component if
you have a Scalar variable.
We claim that if you go and look
at those critical opalescent
pictures that we saw,
and do it more precisely
and see what happens as a
function of the scattered wave
number q, that you
will get a shape that
is 1 over q squared
plus c to the minus 2.
This kind of shape that
is called a Lorentzian
is indeed what you commonly
see for all kinds of scattering
line shapes.
OK?
So we have a prediction.
Of course, the
reason that it works
is because in principle we
know that this series will have
higher order terms
as we discussed
like q to the fourth, q
to the sixth, et cetera,
but they fall way down
here where you're not
going to be seeing
all that much anyway.
Now the place where
this curve turns around
from being something that
is dominated by 1 over K c
to the minus 2 to something
that falls off as 1
over K q squared or
maybe even faster,
the borderline is this inverse
length scale that we indicated,
c l minus 1.
So now what happens if I go
closer to the phase transition
point?
As I go closer to the
phase transition point,
t goes to zero, this c
inverse goes towards zero.
So if this is for some
temperature above Tc
and I go to some lower
temperature, then what happens
is that the curve will start
higher and then [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah?
Actually it doesn't
cross the other curve
which is what I wrote down.
Just because it starts
higher it can bend and go
and join this curve
at a further point.
Eventually when you go through
exactly the critical point then
you get the union of all of
these curves, which is a 1
over q squared type of curve.
So right at the point
where t equals to 0
the prediction is that
the Lorentzian shape,
the coefficient that appears
in front of q squared
vanishes you will see
one over q squared.
OK?
Now the results of experiments
in reality that are very
happily fitted, the
Lorentzian, when you're away
from the critical
point they claim
that when you are exactly
at the critical point,
it's not quite 1 over q squared.
Seems to be slightly different.
At Tc, the scattering
appears to be
more similar to 1 over q
to 2 minus a small amount.
That's where another
critical exponent theta
is introduced so that's another
thing that ultimately you
have to try to figure
out and understand.
OK?
Of course I drew the curves
for the longitudinal component.
If I look at the curves for
the transverse components,
and again, by appropriate choice
of spin polarized neutrons
you can decompose
different components
of scattering from
the magnetization
field of a piece of
iron, for example.
If you are above
Tc, there is really
no difference between
longitudinal and transverse
because there is no
direction that is selected.
And you can see that the forms
that you will get above Tc
would be exactly the same.
When you go below Tc, that's
where the difference appears
because the length
scale that would appear
for the longitudinal
parameters would be finite
and it corresponds
to having to push
the magnetization above this
bottom of the Mexican hat
potential whereas there is no
cost in the other direction.
So if you can probe in
the fluctuations that
would correspond to
these Goldstone modes,
you would see the 1 over q
squared type of behavior.
OK?
So the story that we were
talking about last time around
about the Goldstone
modes and they're
fluctuating a lot because of
their low cost also certainly
remains in this case.
We have now explicitly
separated out
the longitudinal
fluctuations that
are finite because
they are controlled
by this stiffness of going up
the bottom of the potential
whereas there is no
stiffness associated
with the transverse ones.
OK?
All right, so good.
So we've talked about
some of the things that
are experimentally observed.
Any questions?
Now we looked at things here in
the Fourier space corresponding
to this momentum transfer in
the scattering experiment,
but we can also ask about what
is happening in physical space.
That is if I have a
fluctuation at one point,
how much does the influence
of that fluctuation
propagate in space?
So for that I need to calculate
things like phi-- let's say,
do we need to put an
invert, why not?--
phi l of x phi l of x prime.
Let's say we want to
calculate this quantity.
OK?
Now I can certainly
decompose phi l
of x in terms of these
Fourier components.
And so what do I get?
I will get a sum over q-- maybe
I should write it in one case
explicitly, q and q
prime e to i cube of x e
to the i q prime the x prime.
Two factors of root
3 giving me the V
and then I have phi l
of q phi l of q prime
and the expectation
value will go over here.
Now we said that the
different q's and q primes
are uncorrelated.
So here I immediately
will have a delta function
mq plus q prime but if I'm
looking at the same q and q
prime, I have this factor
of 1 over K q squared
plus c to the minus
2-- c l to the minus 2.
OK?
So then the whole thing becomes
due to the delta function
the sum over 1 q of 1
over V each with i q
dot x minus x prime because
q prime was 2 minus q.
And then I have K 2 squared
plus c l to the minus.
OK?
So then I go to the continuum
limit of a large size,
the sum over q gets
replaced with integral
over q d times the
density of state.
The V's disappear,
I will have a factor
of 2 pi to the d and what I have
is the Fourier transform of k q
squared plus c to the
minus-- l to the minus 2.
And I will write this
as minus 1 over K
a function I that
depends on d dimension
and clearly depends
on the separation
x minus x prime at the
correlation length c l.
Why I said correlation length
shortly becomes apparent.
So I introduce a function I
d which depends on x and c
to be minus integral over q 2 pi
to the d Fourier transform of q
squared plus c to the minus 2.
If that c was not there
that's the integral that we
did last time and
it was the Coulomb
potential in d dimension.
So this presumably
is related to that.
And we can use the same
trick that we employed
to make it explicit
last time around.
We can take the Laplacian of
this potential i d and what
happens is that I will
bring two factors of i
q squared so the
minus goes away.
I will have the integral
d d cubed 2 pi to the d.
I will have a q
squared, denominator
is q squared plus
c to the minus 2.
I add and subtract the c to
the minus 2 to the numerator
and I have to Fourier transform.
OK?
The first part if I divide by
the denominator is simply 1.
Integral of Fourier
transform of 1
will give me a delta function.
And then what I have is minus
c squared, the same integral
that I used to define i d.
So this becomes plus i d
of x divided by c squared.
OK?
So whereas in the
absence of c you have
the potential do to a
charge, the presence of c
adds this additional
term that corresponds
to some kind of a damping.
So this equation
you probably have
seen in the context of
screened Coulomb interaction
and giving rise to the
[INAUDIBLE] potential
in three dimensions.
We would like to look
at it in d dimension
so that we know what the
behavior is in general.
OK?
So again what I'm looking
at is the potential
that is due to a
charge at the origin
so this idea of x
in principle only
depends on the magnitude of x
and not on the direction of it.
It is something that has
general spherical symmetry
in d dimensions.
So I use that fact
of spherical symmetry
to write down what the
expression for the Laplacian
is.
OK?
We can again use Gauss's
law if you've forgotten
or whatever but in the
presence of spherical symmetry
the general expression for
Laplacian in d dimension
is this.
OK?
So if this d was
equal to 1 it would
be a simple second derivative.
And in higher dimensions you
would have additional factors
if you basically apply Gauss's
law to shares around here.
You can very easily
convince yourself of that.
This is some kind
of an aerial term
that comes in d
minus 1 dimension.
And then I can write this as
either the second derivative
if d by the x acts on
this, the x to the minus 1
disappears or if it
acts on this one,
it will gives me d
minus 1 x to the d
minus 2, x to the d minus 1
gives me an x, the i by d x.
So the equation
that I have to solve
is this object equals to i over
c squared plus a delta function
[INAUDIBLE].
OK?
Now if you vary one
dimension you wouldn't
have this term at all and you
would have-- except that x
equals to 0, the second
derivative proportional
to the function
divided by c squared.
So you will
immediately write a way
x equals to 0 that the answer
is e to the minus x over c.
OK?
Actually proportional
because you
have to fit out with the
amplitude, et cetera.
Now in higher
dimensions what happens
is that this solution
gets modified,
falls off with some
additional x to the p
but we have to be somewhat
careful with this.
So let's look at this a
little bit more closely.
If I were to substitute this
ansatz into this expression,
what would happen?
What I need to do is to take
the first and the second
derivative.
Now if I take the
first derivative,
the derivative either
acts on this factor,
gives me a factor of
minus 1 over c and then
the exponential back,
so I can get the i back.
If I had an exponential
I take a derivative,
I will get just minus
1 over psi exponential.
If I act on x to the
minus b I will get minus p
x to the p minus 1, which is
different from the original
solution by a
factor of p over x.
OK?
If I now take two derivatives I
can take the second derivative
on I itself and then d
I by d x will give me I
back with this factor.
So I will get 1 over c squared
plus 2 P c x plus P squared
over x squared with
I but that's not
the whole story because the
derivative can also leave I
aside and act on P over
x, which if it does so,
it will get P over
x squared so that
will be an additional term here.
So that's the second derivative.
So now what I have done
is I have evaluated
with this ansatz the
terms that should appear
in that equation of a from
x equals to 0, so let's
substitute it.
Everything now I have is
proportional to I so I just
forget about the I.
I have the second
derivative 1 over c
squared plus 2 P
divided by x c plus p p
plus 1 divided by x squared.
And then I have d minus
1, the first derivative,
so I have minus d minus 1 over
c minus d minus 1 p over x.
Both of these terms get
an additional factor
of x because of here so I
will get x c and x squared
and what I have on the right
hand side from the origin
is I over c squared.
Divide by the I, I
have 1 over c squared.
Now if I'm moving away
from x I can organize
things in powers of 1 over x.
The most important
term is the constant
and clearly you can see
that I chose the decay
constant of the
exponential correctly as
evidenced by the
absence or removal of 1
over the constant
term on the two sides.
But now I have two terms,
two types of terms.
Terms that are proportional
to x squared and terms
that are proportional
to x psi and there's
no way that I can simultaneously
satisfy both of these.
So the assumption that the
solution of this equation
is a single exponential
divided by a power law
is in fact not correct.
But it can be correct
in two regions.
So for x that is much
less than psi then
the more important term is
the 1 over x squared part.
For x but going towards
0 the 1 over x squared
is more important than 1 over x.
OK so then what I do is
I will match these two
terms and those two terms that
are 1 over x squared tell me
that P p plus 1
should be P d minus 1.
OK?
And that immediately getting
rid of the p's tells me
that the P in this
regime is d minus 2.
OK?
Now the d minus 2
you recall is what
we had for the
Coulomb potential.
Right?
So basically at
short distances you
are still not screened
by this additional term.
You don't see its effect
and you get essentially
the standard Coulomb potential
whereas if you are away
what you get is that you
have to match the terms that
are proportional to x c because
they're more important than 1
over x squared.
And there you get that
2 P should be d minus 1
or P should be d minus 1 over 2.
OK?
So let's just plot that
function over here.
So if I plot this function as
a function of the separation x
and it only depends
on the magnitude,
in fact, what I
should plot is minus i
d because it's
the minus i d that
depends on the
fluctuations once I divide
by K. I find that
it has two regimes.
Let's say above two dimensions
you have one regime that
is a simple Coulomb
type of potential
and the Coulomb
potential last time
actually we normalized properly.
We saw that it is x to the
2 minus d S d d minus 2.
The e to x into the
minus x over c I
can in fact ignore
in this regime
because I'm at distance x
that is much less than c
so the exponential term
has not kicked in yet
whereas I go at large distances
and the exponential term does
kick in.
So the overall behavior is
e to the minus x over c.
That's the most dominant
behavior that you have.
On top of that, we
have a power log
which is x to the power
of d minus 1 over 2.
Now those of you who know
what the screened Coulomb
potential is know that the
screened Coulomb potential
in three dimensions is the 1
over r, the Coulomb potential,
and you put an exponential
on top of that.
There is no difference
in the powers
that you have whether
or not you are
smaller than this
correlation length or larger.
You can check here, if
I put d equals to 3,
this becomes a 1 over x and
this becomes a 1 over x.
So it's just an accident
of three dimensions
that the screened
Coulomb potential
is the 1 over r with
an exponential on top.
In general dimensions you
have different powers.
But having different
powers also means
that somehow the
amplitude that goes over
here has to carry dimensions so
that it can be matched to what
we have here at
this distance of C.
And so if I try to match
those terms, roughly
when you're at order of c,
what I would do is I would put
s d d minus 2 and c to
the 3 minus d over 2.
And now you can check
that the two expressions
will have the right dimension
and will match roughly
at order of c.
OK?
So essentially what it says is
that if I ask in my system what
is the nature of
these fluctuations,
how correlated they
are, they would
know to be more or less the same
although falling off as if you
were at the critical
point because we said
that the critical point or
when you have Goldstone modes,
you have just this term.
But then they know that
you are not exactly
sitting at the
critical point and then
they are no longer correlated.
So basically there
is this length scale
that we also saw
when we were looking
at these critical
opalescence and we
were seeing things that
were moving together.
That length scale where
things are moving together
is this parameter c that
we have defined over here.
So what we have is-- where
do we want to put it?
Let's put it here.
A correlation length
which measures
the extent to which things
are fluctuating together,
although when I'm saying
fluctuating together,
they are still correlations
that are falling off
but they're not falling
off exponentially.
They start to fall
off exponentially
when you are beyond
this length scale c.
And we have the formula for c.
So what we find
is that if I were
to invert that, for
example, what I find for c l
as a function of t is that it is
simply square root of k over t
when I am on the
t positive side.
When I go to the
t negative side,
it just becomes square
root of K minus 2 t.
OK?
So this correlation length
I indicated we could state
has behavior close
to a transition,
there's a divergence.
We can parametrize those
divergences through something
like t minus Tc to exponent
u, potentially different
on the two sides
of the transition.
But this t is simply
proportional to the real t
minus Tc so we
conclude that u plus is
the same as u minus we've
just indicated by u,
should be one-half.
The amplitudes themselves
depend on all kinds of things.
We don't know much about them.
But we can see that
the amplitude ratio B
plus over B minus, if I
were to divide those two
the ratio of those
two is universal,
it gives me a factor
of square root of 2.
OK?
If I were to plot
c t, for example,
on the high temperature side c t
and c l are of course the same.
On the low temperature side, we
said that the Goldstone modes
have these long
range correlations.
They fall off or grow according
to the Coulomb potential
but there is no length
scale so in some sense
the correlation length
for the transverse modes
is always infinity.
OK.
Now actually in the
second lecture what I said
was that the fact
that the response
function such as
susceptibility diverges
immediately tells you
that there have to be long
range correlations,
so we had predicted
before that c has to diverge.
But we were not sufficiently
precise about the way
that it does, so
let's try to do that.
Let's see.
A relationship more
precisely with susceptibility
and these correlation
lengths, so what we said more
generally was that the
susceptibilities up
to various factors of data,
et cetera, that are not
that important are related to
the integrated magnetization
to magnetization
connected correlation.
So basically, what
I have to do is
to look at m minus
its average at x,
m minus its average at
some other point, which
means that what I'm
really looking at
is the phi phi averages.
OK?
Now what we have
shown right now is
that these averages
are significant.
These phi phi correlations
are significant
only over a distance that
is this correlation length
and then they die off.
So we could basically as
far as scaling and things
like that is concerned
terminate this integration at c.
And that when we are looking at
distances that are below that,
you don't see the effect
of the exponential,
you just see the
Coulomb power law
so you would see
here fluctuations
that decay as x
to the 2 minus d.
Right?
So essentially what you're doing
is integrating x to the 2 minus
d in d dimension of space.
So you can see that
immediately gets related
to the square of the
correlation length.
X to the minus d n d d
x, the d part vanishes,
there's a 2 that remains
and gives you c squared.
If you like you can write
it in spherical coordinates,
et cetera, but dimensions
have to work out
to be something like this.
So now we can-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify, when
you sat phi of x and phi of 0,
are those both longitudinal
or both transverse?
PROFESSOR: I wasn't precise
so if I, thinking about chi l,
these will be both longitudinal.
OK?
And then we have
this expression.
If I'm talking about chi t
and I'm above the transition
temperature, there's no problem.
If I'm below the
transition temperature,
I can use the same
thing but have
to set c to infinity
so I have to integrate
all the way to infinity.
OK?
But now you can see that the
divergence of susceptibility
is very much related to the
divergence of correlations,
in some sense very
precisely in that
if this goes like t
to the minus gamma
and the correlation length
diverges as t to the minus u,
then gamma should be 2 nu.
And indeed, our ne is one-half.
We had seen previously
that gamma was 2 nu.
Secondly that the amplitude
ratio for susceptibility
should be the square
of the amplitude ratio
for the correlation
length and again this
is something that
we have seen before.
The amplitude ratio
for susceptibility
was the square root of 2.
Now it turns out
that all of this
is a gain within this
[INAUDIBLE] point approximation
looking at the most
probable state, et cetera.
Because what we find in reality
is that at the critical point,
the correlations don't decay
simply according to the Coulomb
law but there is
this additional eta
which is the same eta
that we had over here.
OK?
And that because of that
eta, here what you would have
is 2 minus eta and you
would get an example
of a number of things that
we will see a lot later on.
That is there even if you don't
know what the exponents are,
you know that there
are relationships
among the exponents.
This is an example of an
exponent identity called
a Fisher exponent
and there are several
of these exponents identities.
OK?
But that also brings
us to the following-
that we did all of this
work and we came up
with answers for the singular
behaviors at critical points
and why they are universal.
And actually as far as the
thermodynamic quantities
were concerned, all
we ended up doing
was to write some expression
that was analytical
and then find its minimum.
And we found that the minimum
of an analytical expression
always has the same type
of singularities, which
we can characterize
by these exponents.
So maybe it's now a
good time to check
how these match
with the experiment.
So let's look at the various
types of phase transition,
an example of the material
that undergoes that phase
transition, and what the
exponents alpha, beta, gamma,
and u are that are
experimentally obtained.
AUDIENCE: What is this again?
PROFESSOR: The material
that undergoes a transition,
so for example when we are
talking about the ferromagnet
to paramagnet transition,
you could look at material
such as iron or
nickel and if we ask
in the context of
this systematics
that we were developing for
the Landau-Ginzburg what they
correspond to, they are things
that have three components
or fields so they
correspond to n equals to 3.
Of course everything that I will
be talking to in this column
will correspond to
3-dimensional systems.
Later we'll talk also about
2-dimensional and other
systems, but let's stick with
real 3-dimensional world.
So that would be one set.
We will look at super fluidity.
Let's say in helium, which
we discussed last semester,
that corresponds
to n equals to 2.
We will talk about various
examples of liquid gas
transition which correspond to
a scalar density difference.
And this could be anything
from say carbon dioxide, neon,
argon, whatever gas we like.
And also talk about
superconductors
which to all
intents and purposes
should have the same type of
symmetries as super fluids.
An example of a quantum system
should be n equals to 2,
gained lots of different cases
such as aluminum, copper,
whatever.
So what do we find
for the exponent?
Actually for
ferromagnetic system
the heat capacity
does not diverge.
It has a discontinuous
derivative at the transition
and kind of goes in a manner
that if you take its derivative
then the derivative appears
to be singular and corresponds
to an alpha.
If you try to fit it to
it's slightly negative.
The superfluid has this famous
lambda shape for its heat
capacity and a lambda
shape is very well fitted
to a logarithm type of function.
The logarithm is the
limit of a power law
as the exponent goes to 0 so we
can more or less indicate that
by an alpha of 0 or really
it's a divergent log.
These objects, the
liquid gas transition
does have weakly
divergent heat capacity
so the alpha is around 0.1.
The values of betas are
all less than one-half,
for ferromagnet system
is of the order of 0.4.
It is almost one-third, slightly
less for superfluid helium
and less for the
liquid gas system.
Gammas something like 1.4.
We don't have a
gamma for superfluid,
you can't put a magnetic
field on the superfluid.
There's nothing that is
conjugate to the quantum phase.
Here it is more like 1.3.
Mu is 0.-- it's
not-- [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
So what I have here it is more
like 1.3, 1.24, 0.7, 0.67,
0.63.
OK?
Now they are different from
the predictions that we had.
Predictions that we had where
alpha was 0 discontinuous.
Beta goes to one-half.
Gamma was 1, mu
equals to one-half.
And actually these
predictions that we just made
happen to match extremely
well with all kinds
of super conducting
systems that you look at.
So again it is
important to state
that within a particular
class like liquid gas
you can do a lot of
different systems.
We saw that curve in
the second lecture.
They all correspond to
this same set of exponents,
singularly for a different
magnet and so forth.
So there is something
that is universal
but our Landau-Ginzburg
approach with this looking
at the most probable state
and fluctuations around
it has not captured
it for most cases
but for some reason
has captured it
for the case of superconductors.
So we have that puzzle and
starting from next lecture
we'll start to unravel that.